[Music]
I had just gone upstairs it hadn't even
started raining yet and then
something weird
some weird strange sound happening
[Music]
I knew it was a tornado
our roof was literally picked up and
flown across the street and crushed two
cars it was absolutely terrifying
this was the aftermath it was totally
like a bomb went off I mean it was
devastating
smashed glass shards of metal and debris
covered Rob garrard's Brewery
earlier they were celebrating the May
long weekend in 2022. it was the first
time Rob's Uxbridge Ontario business had
been open in close to two years because
of the pandemic the place was packed I
think we were just lucky that nobody was
seriously hurt
but the brewery was destroyed
that tornado was part of a dorecho a
rare storm system which traveled through
Ontario into Quebec it killed 12 people
so it was a tragic event it also caused
more than a billion dollars of insured
losses
[Music]
Gregory comp has been to several sites
like this before the Civil and
environmental engineering Professor has
spent decades trying to make homes more
resilient to windstorms if it had proper
nailing the roof would have stayed on to
do that he and the team from the
northern tornadoes project at Western
University in London Ontario have been
studying the Carnage left behind we have
to understand how buildings perform in
them so that we can assess the intensity
but while we're doing that we can also
understand how to design better
part of Gregory's work is to figure out
how many tornadoes Canada gets using
radar and satellite imagery the group
discovered the country ranks number two
for the most tornadoes Canada's second
in the world as we've found tornadoes
all the way from Vancouver Island to
Newfoundland and from the southernmost
point of Canada and all the way to the
Northwest Territories because
tornadoes touch down in areas with no
Witnesses so the numbers have been
underestimated why do we care about this
if we want to really know the true
occurrence of tornadoes in Canada we
need to find them and develop better
models for that so it's actually
important especially as a population
grows and we spread out what is the true
level of risk
[Music]
they're also trying to figure out the
risk to structures
using a wind tunnel at the wind
engineering energy and environment Dome
known as windy Engineers can assess how
buildings will handle extreme winds
the massive facility is filled with
almost floor-to-ceiling fans that can
simulate a variety of different wind
systems we wanted to see firsthand how
it worked so we met up with
guillermabitswamlak the director of
windy how does a tornado actually affect
a building when wind in taraksu is any
building primarily it produces suction
you know except in the face where the
wind hits it you know that it produces
pressure when the wind increases the
pressure reduces you know so these are
high velocity event and the pressure
drops significantly way below the
atmospheric pressure that's why the roof
lies
germa gives us a demonstration using a
residential neighborhood but the study
building is installed with this kind of
pressure tops you know during the test
basically we measure the pressure on all
these dot points here the team studies
the aerodynamic forces that develop
during different wind systems so that
buildings can be designed to be stronger
this facility gets requests for testing
from around the world
the sensors measure the pressure
experienced by a building During a
severe Windstorm after repeat testing
the results go into a database
it is those type of information that are
used then to establish building code and
standards and developers to take that
information and use it to build wiser
buildings yes wiser and more tornado
resilient buildings
the resilience of buildings especially
our homes could become critically
important as the effects of climate
change worsen so far updates to Canadian
building codes to tackle global warming
have mostly been focused on Energy
Efficiency standards geared at changing
weather patterns are based on historic
records although codes are continuously
under review the weather's changing
so designing for the past 50 years
prepares us for the past 50 years it
doesn't prepare us for the next 50 years
Keith Porter is the chief engineer of
the institute for catastrophic loss
reduction an independent not-for-profit
Research Center founded by the insurance
industry and also affiliated with
Western University
he says many new homes today are not
built for extreme wind conditions we
collect all this anemometer data and
then we pretend that there are no
tornadoes at least as far as the
building code goes we have known that we
could design for tornadoes and just
chose not to foreign
this became abundantly clear after a
violent tornado hit Barry Ontario in
Adam The Roof Is Gone Natalie Harris and
her son Adam took cover in the basement
of her ex-partner's home when she
emerged pink insulation was falling from
the sky looked up and saw the roof was
gone and it was raining into the house
and there was other people's stuff in
the front hall I think I said oh my God
multiple times
oh my God
I have Goosebumps even right now
thinking about it
the Twister which topped out at 210
kilometers an hour ripped through this
neighborhood peeling roofs off homes and
sending shingles flying no one was
killed there and I always think that
that's a miracle when you have roofs
coming off houses flying through the air
that debris is really dangerous
Gregory was on the ground within hours
to survey the damage when you've been to
a few of these events you see repetitive
patterns on building performance one of
the weakest links on our houses is how
the roof is fastened to the walls and so
often in these events the the whole roof
comes off and you're just left there
with walls top of the wall are these two
by fours Gregory says the solution that
could minimize this problem is
installing hurricane straps or Clips the
small bracket made of galvanized steel
is used to strengthen the connection
between the roof and the wall helping
the roof stay attached during aggressive
winds this technology has been around
for a long time it's been established we
know it works it's just not common here
I had no clue
no clue I had no idea I'm like what do
you mean a hurricane strap After the
Storm Natalie who is a city councilor at
the time decided to learn more about
building codes
since Barry had been devastated by a
tornado before in 1985 she was surprised
by the lack of wind resilience
guidelines in place
how are houses after the 80s not being
built by the standard that we should
have because we get these wins and it's
not the city that really mandates that
it's the province so immediately I
started working to really try to get to
the bottom of why that wasn't happening
in Berry and how we can change it so
Natalie backed a proposal to change
Ontario building codes to have better
extreme wind measures including
hurricane straps
she's out of politics now but continues
to advocate for them we know that
climate change is just ravaging the
world right now this is not a if it will
be when will this happen again so let's
make sure we're taking all the steps
properly but we're still waiting for
Progress politics is slow
hurricane straps aren't mandatory in
Canada the National Building Code
requires each roof to wall connection to
be fastened by three Nails about three
inches long called toenails
the code doesn't require it a lot of
Premium Builders will use it but it's
not required so it doesn't get done
the argument against adding hurricane
straps to the code is cost experts say
some of the building industry feel the
extra expense is not justified the cost
of installing hurricane straps on a
house can vary depending on the size of
the roof and the cost of Labor the
bracket itself is a few dollars it's
coming out of the pockets of the people
who are making the decision about the
building code and until you can show
them we really really need to they will
resist change one possible solution
Keith suggests is to spread the
financial burden among governments
Builders owners and insurance companies
for example municipalities could give
developers breaks on fees or insurance
companies could give discounts to
homeowners who have installed hurricane
straps we create these incentives in
such a way that it becomes less
expensive to build new buildings to be
resilient so there are ways to do that
we asked the Canadian homebuilders
Association a residential construction
industry group with over 8 500 companies
if hurricane straps should be included
into the code the association replied
hurricane straps alone are not a silver
bullet the whole house needs to be
considered you can't simply add
hurricane straps without assessing the
impacts on the rest of the structure
or you could have failures in other
areas I think we should be putting this
in the code and I think we should be
thinking about resilience measures in
general houses are with us for a long
time and we want them to be with us for
a long time
almost all the ceilings up there looking
good
that Canucks Bridge the second wedge
Brewing Company is rebuilding on the day
we met up with Rob Garrard and his wife
and co-founder Joanne Richter that were
on site admiring the progress
we've gone through all the emotions I
guess in the last year
when we finally started to rebuild it
started to feel better they decided not
to shut down but rather build back
better
for just trying to rebuild our business
and make it a little better and safer
and that includes hurricane straps Robin
Joanne are planning to reopen the
business on the long weekend in May the
one-year anniversary of the tornado
while construction won't be done by then
the two will put up a tent in the garden
hoping to see some familiar faces and
have some laughs once again
I missed the customers we have a really
good bond with people of the community
and to get back to normal it would be
just such a dream